hi
hi as the war in Gaza rages violence
against Palestinians in the West Bank is
surging according to Palestinian
villagers Israeli settler attacks like
these have been happening almost daily
so right now A group of settlers kind of
moved up to the road here to try
intimidate Palestinian farmers who live
on this land
these guys are coming in large groups
with
[Music]
weapons I'm in the town of KRA in the
West Bank this is a Palestinian village
where six people were killed in just a
24-hour period the villagers we're
talking to here are saying that the
attacks and intimidation from settlers
has gone into overdrive this is one of
the bloodiest periods in the West Bank
in 15 years with so much attention
focused on Gaza and focused in the north
of the country so many of the
Palestinians here are worried that they
will be next in line to be
attacked at the height of the olive
harvest season Abdul aim wadii Works
under the watch of an IDF
Outpost his family has lived on this
land for three
[Music]
generations on October 12th Abdul was
with his brother ibraim and nephew Ahmed
attending a funeral for four
Palestinians who had been killed the
previous
[Music]
day according to Abdul who was just a
the road in the funeral procession this
video shows armed settlers stopping
their car and opening fire on ibraim and
Ahmed hours later the two men died at
the
hospital Abdul says they were unarmed
after the attack settlers have since
claimed they had been terrorists
offering no
evidence
during our interview a group of armed
Israeli settlers
approached as the settlers walk further
and further
forward the Israeli military
intervenes the IDF has stepped in to
kind of pull the settlers back so there
was there was no violence but
Palestinian people that were with here
the farmers are saying this is happening
almost every
day
Muslim